avec certitude le fait divers qui ces
dernières années passionne le plus grand
nombre de français l'affairé xavier
dupont de ligonnès du nom de ce père de
famille catholique aisée et ranger qui
du jour au lendemain a été accusé
d'avoir abattu ses quatre enfants et sa
femme puis de les avoir enterrés sous la
terrasse de leur maison près de nantes
après la disparition de toute une
famille cinq corps ont été déjà retrouvé
en cavale depuis 2011 l'histoire folle
de ce père de famille qui était en fait
rongé par les dettes
empêtré dans des mensonges et
probablement enrôlé dans une secte n'en
finit plus de faire parler
cet été c'est l' enquête du magazine
society qui a passionné les français
suivi d'un documentaire événement sur
netflix et enfin un téléfilm diffusé par
m6 intitulé un homme ordinaire
[Musique]
aujourd'hui de nouvelles informations
viennent de paraître au sujet de ce
quintuple meurtre
c'est bruno de stabenrath un ancien ami
de xavier dupont de ligonnès qui révèle
dans son livre l'ami impossible
l'existence d'un demi frère qui l'aurait
beaucoup fait souffrir
il raconte aussi la façon dont xavier
dupont de ligonnès aurait été contraint
d'accepter les infidélités de sa femme
pour éviter de se retrouver sur la
paille ce soir bruno de stabenrath était
avec nous sur notre plateau pour tout
nous raconter de cette affaire aussi
terrible que fascinante
merci bruno d'être avec nous vous pouvez
bien sûr réagir un bien sûr autour de la
table alors bruno vous dites que xavier
dupont de ligonnès comme vous il est né
d'une famille très noble son père avait
même le titre de comte
mais son père un bel homme chaleureux
selon-vous bono a quitté le foyer quand
son fils avait une dizaine d'années oui
c'est l'époque où moi je les ai connus
enfin pas plus tard ouais ils n'en
parlaient pas plu à son son père était
parti en afrique refaire sa vie et
xavier s'y retrouver un peu le l'enfant
roi
ma seule au milieu des trois femmes et
c'est une famille très heureuse moi
quand je les ai connus en terminale
c'est un garçon c'est pour ça que tu es
mon avis aussi les mais elle vise les
beach boys les cabriolets et il m'a
jamais parlé de ça enfin de d'expliquer
sa souffrance du fait que son père était
parti
et puis même un jour il organise un
déjeuner ils vont organiser avec son
père ah ouais auquel il n'a pas
participé non et je lui ai dit mais
pourquoi tu veux je rencontre ton père
vous organisez un d une action permet en
fait
en fait je pense qu'il voulait alors je
me suis dit est-ce que c'est sa mère qui
a demandé à ce que je dirai que son père
pour vérifier que j'étais un bon copain
mais quand elle est pas emmener xavier
sur des pistes selon la quelle qu'elle
soit ou tout simplement moi j'ai pensé
que son père qui était un homme très
chaleureux et très curieux et très open
mind voulu savoir pourquoi j'étais
comédien pourquoi enfin tu rigoles élus
s'intéressent à ma vie alors xavier
dupont de ligonnès il est né le 9
janvier 1961 à versailles dans les
yvelines
il est apprécié au lycée ou pas à
l'époque oui enfin il était assez
réservé 1
il était assez comment dire on va pas
dire timide mais vous avez il n'a jamais
été à l'aise
comment dire avec en société l'accueil
est métro de londres et qu'il aimait
bien sortir vous disais l'aimé bien
sorti living qu'on avait 16 ans 18 enfin
heureusement mais après moi moi je suis
parti à paris et lui étaient pas du tout
le monde 1 était pas du tout parisien
il est parti tout de suite avec la
liaison sud enfin c'est quelqu'un qui
voulait sa famille qui voulait son petit
monde
il n'était pas du tout dans les plans
avec beaucoup de gens et faire la fête
alors oui on vous dit il avait un but
dans sa vie c'était faire très
rapidement fortune basse comme a comme
on a 20 ans on voulait partir aux états
unis on voulait conquérir le monde c'est
normal et toute sa vie il a fait
beaucoup de voyages aux états unis enfin
moi et me raconter mon envoyé des photos
des cartes postales et je le comprenais
sauf que malheureusement c'était un
piètre gestionnaire et toutes les
sociétés qu'il a montée ont tout fait
faillite
donc c'est quelqu'un qui s'est retrouvé
à la fin de sa vie totalement acculé
alors pour bien comprendre le personnage
de xavier dupont de ligonnès faut
comprendre aussi le rôle trouble de sa
mère dans son évolution
geneviève dupont de ligonnès que vous
connaissez qui l'a élevé seule mais pour
beaucoup elle est la cause des déviances
de son fils xavier
il disait quoi sur sa mère pour moi
c'est difficile
enfin ça divise en parler parce que mon
mât élevées pour défendre la veuve et
l'orphelin mais là je me retrouve si
vous voulez sur les plateaux c'est vrai
que j'ai une pédagogie end en mai contre
la mère de xavier et sa soeur pour la
bonne et simple raison qu'ils disent que
ce sont pas les corps qu'on a retrouvés
sous la terrasse
et ça c'est quelque chose que je peux
pas entendre je peux pas entendre
qu'ont ils à mort ses enfants et d'agnès
mais pour revenir à l'enfance et xavier
moi je m'en suis pas rendu compte parce
qu'ils en parlaient pas il avait une vie
de jeune homme moderne normal comme
comme comme la mienne
et puis c'est avec les années que j'ai
découvert qu'il avait on va dire quoi
une vie parallèle à ces dire qu'ils
avaient une mère qui était mystique qui
recevaient des messages du très haut qui
avait fondé une halte à la tête d'une
secte religieuse à bercy la dette alors
ce n'était pas une secte parce qu'une
secte c'est quelque chose qui marche
moi j c'est un groupe de prières fermé
puisqu'il y avait ce qu'on appelait le
jardin s'étaient tous les membres qui
étaient proches dans le premier cercle
est donc géré enquêter là dessus et j'ai
retrouvé des gens de la fin du groupe de
prières fermé mais un moment ce que
j'explique dans le livre c'est que tout
était en place pour que ça devienne une
vraie secte mais ça y est maintenant
euros il y avait des miracles y'avait
geneviève qu'avait des messages du très
haut il y avait les avez les adeptes
tout était prêt et sauf que c'était un
peu une escroquerie on va dire
intellectuelle et gdf s'est retrouvé
avec ses 40 50
ils ont jamais été plus que sa constance
indien la mer mais où xavier oxygène ont
dit qu'elle était un peu folle avec des
fréquentations particulière selon
beaucoup de ses proches sa mère disait
xavier dupont de ligonnès était l'élu
qui s'ouvre est le bon
de l'apocalypse et ces deux là tout
devient tout drame de ma vie' puisqu'en
95 c'est là où je raconte vraiment là
enfin hier un sou dans les clans shirt
c'est à dire que philadelphia la mère
geneviève a réuni tous les membres de la
secte fondée ferrand droit parce que là
il va se passer l'apocalypse d'accord
donc là à saint maxin xavier se réunit
avec sa femme des amis et emmanuel
teneur qui était le meilleur ami
[ __ ] mes amis aussi qui était le
meilleur ami de xavier qui l'a suivi
pendant 37 ans qui dîner avec lui la
veille des crimes donc emmanuel m'a
raconté des choses très intéressantes et
il était là il était là présent le soir
de juin 95 ou l'apocalypse doit passer
sauf que emmanuel a pris des distances
avec la sec il a compris que ça tournait
pas rond
mais le spontané à xavier parce que
c'est mon pote on va tendre on va voir
ce qui se passe mais c'est très bien que
rien ne va se passer
et alors on ne se passe j'avais dupont
de ligonnès rencontre sa femme agnès
dans les années 80 à versailles
sauf que si elle rêve de vie de famille
de mariage lui est encore un peu court
heures adore faire la fête c'est un
appareil les jeunes il a 20 ans et est
un été il va rencontrer une très belle
allemande
ouais alors qu'il est déjà fiancée avec
agnès et et il va passer de versailles à
la belle allemande le blonde aux yeux
bleus bon il donc iront s'est fiancée à
rien et puis va partir aux etats-unis va
faire plusieurs voyages nous on se voit
assez régulièrement et en 89 sa mère
l'appelle puisqu'entre temps agnès était
resté un peu dans la secte dans
l'entourage de geneviève puisque s'avère
l'aimé beaucoup et puis en 89 sa mère
l'appelle unis xavier finit-on fini des
embuscades fini tes voyages états unis
tu reviens en france sur épouse agnès et
agnès était père d'un petit garçon
anja cité mais ouais là d'un petit
arthur ans que c'est à quelques mois
pour elle rencontre xavier de ligonnès
met fin à sa relation avec agnès
réconfort dans les bras d'un autre homme
elle aura un enfant que cet homme refuse
de reconnaître refuse de reconnaître ce
qui est pas terrible ailleurs enfin bref
et connaître arthur voilà et xavier va
élever arthur comme comme son fils et
c'était assez son match est assez noble
dans ces années là parce qu'à versailles
on épouse est pas une fille mère tu vois
c'était un peu exagéré il a pris tout le
il a pris tout le concept est il a fondé
une vraie famille avec agnès et ils sont
partis dans le sud très vite
sauf que le conte de fées rêvé par les
deux amants ne verra jamais le jour
puisque après avoir été dans le var aux
etats unis la vis la famille s'installe
à nanterre et c'est à ce moment là que
débute vraiment les galères ah non
excusez moi et oui on enterre ses plus
proches et c'était quoi son métier
exactement à xavier dupont de ligonnès
n'a jamais compris rats equity la montée
moi je me souviens à l'époque en 2001
grâce à internet la bulle internet il
voulait et il a monté dans des sites la
route des voyageurs la route des
commerciaux parce qu'il était tout le
temps en fait
xavier c'était quoi le mec est sur les
routes toute la semaine on sait ce qu'il
faisait ou pas du tout bah oui il était
comme on appelle ça gênerait pas
représentants de québec et sur les
routes là il a monté sa boîte pour aller
voir les hôtels et restaurants les
mouettes de nuire disant voilà je vous
référencie sur mon site
et puis vous ferez des réductions mais
les clients du amènerait mais ça n'a
jamais marché puis à à la fin il a
démonté ce qu'on appelle éthique et
crystal qui était une fin moi je veux
dire franchement j'ai jamais compris
déjà pourquoi xavier qu'avait eu son bac
avec un an d'avancé qui était brillant
n'a pas fait de grandes études srg
compris après et pourquoi il a monté des
sociétaires faillite est pas doué pour
ce à quoi tout simplement
oui j'ai oublié qu'à incroyable dans le
livre qui est passionnant sur 500 ma
page c'est que ça retrace l'itinéraire
de xavier dupont de ligonnès et on voit
que finalement c'était inéluctable il ya
l'argent cyril l'a dit et à la secte et
puis à le couple aussi disloqué un
moment avec notamment la tromperie que
dupont de ligonnès ne va pas su alors
justement à ça et les gars ce n'est
guère s'enchaînent donc pour le couple
de ligonnès entre faillite et projet qui
échoue juste au 19 avril jour où la
police nantaise ouvre une enquête pour
disparition inquiétante de la famille de
ligonnès le 21 avril un avis de
recherche est lancé pour toute la
famille mais dans la journée les
enquêteurs découvrent sur la terrasse de
la maison donc les restes humains de la
mère et ses quatre enfants
vous qui le connaissez extrêmement bien
comment vous avez vécu ces journées
c'est à dire qu'avant quand trouvent les
corps donc le 21 le jeudi 21 avril
il ya eu à la famille calmes et disparus
parce que quand vous avez quatre enfants
qui disparaissent des réseaux sociaux de
facebook instagram
moi j'avais le fils d'un copain qui
était qu'ils voyent arthur et qui me dit
la famille a disparu donc ça c'est la
semaine du 3 au 4 avril
on pense que c'est dans la nuit ou
xavier a tué agnès
arthur thomas n'en thomas anne et benoît
parce que deux jours après il va
chercher thomas ce qui est terrible
voyez que le mec il est sûr bref et donc
la famille a disparu
et puis une semaine après on reçoit la
fameuse lettre coucou tout le monde où
il dit j'ai été exfiltré avec ma famille
par l'adie la brigade des stups la
vienne qu'il avait reçu cette lettre
non parce que c'était les légendes
nantes et sa famille proche très proche
parce qu'ils avaient des missions à
chacun on reprend les allocations
reprendre tous les sacs à porter chez
emmaüs
enfin il a laissé un liste avec toutes
les missions alors justement regarder
cette lettre envoyée aux proches regarde
du conte de jeunesse explique dans son
courrier qu'il a été approché par l'as
des as donc le service des stupéfiants
américains pour infiltrer des
trafiquants sur le territoire français
je suis devenu un témoin essentiel dans
un futur procès impliquant des hauts
responsables du trafic de drogue
international
nous sommes donc pris en charge par le
gouvernement américain est transféré aux
usa si c'est vraiment la vérité on va
pas écrire ça à tout le monde
j'écris cette lettre sous contrôle ex
texte c'est la dernière lettre qu'on
peut vous envoyer après on disparaît on
part aux états unis vous ne reverrez
plus on expliquant pourquoi c'est même
pas vrai semblables ouais sa lettre
c'est là c'est vraiment pour moi c'est
sa lettre c'est ce qui l'a que c'est sa
plus grosse erreur parce qu'il n'aurait
pas écrit une lettre
on allait chercher une famille avec
quatre enfants donc la police hurlent fc
une autre une autre démarche
et puis dans cette lettre et de raisons
tu as lease de tout ce qui va donner
voiture les chiens les trucs enfin c'est
que des mensonges en fait à ce que des
monceaux est la seule chose qui
mentionne pas dans cette lettre qui fait
presque huit pages que tout le monde
avait depuis six mois c'est la carabine
c'est la manne de long rifle alors qu'il
aurait pu dire que les données clés
vendus sur internet ou jeunes et ils
n'en parlent pas et pourquoi il en parle
pas parce que c'est l'armé du crime
alors sa mère et sa soeur pense qu'il
est innocent vous pour vous des
coupables
oui indéniablement à 100%
vous qui le connaissez les antilles
équipe qui voulait tuer cette famille tu
voulais imaginer qu'il aurait pu faire
ça non mais non enfin on personne ne
peut imaginer ça en fin de mois je le
connaissais depuis face est un garçon
que j'aime beaucoup et personne ne peut
comprendre ça mais si vous voulez mais
la première question que je me suis
posée quand il a quand même fait
reprendre à trouver les corps quand on
savait xavier temps fuite s'est mis
d'accord vous être copain avec quelqu'un
enfin quand vous engagez en amour en
amitié
est-ce que vous fixez limites est ce que
vous dites à ce moment là ça dépasse la
limite c'est plus mon ami moi c'est pas
dans mes valeurs et puis surtout que je
suis pas le bon dieu je suis pas juge
je suis pas avocat je dois me tenir à
mon rôle d'ami ce qui ne veut pas dire
que le juge pas que je trouve pas ce
qu'il a fait à bout minable mais pour
moi c'est important de comprendre
d'avoir la vérité la justice est de
savoir pourquoi xavier qui avait a
priori quand il était jeune toutes les
cartes en main pour être sur sa vie est
devenue l'assassin de sa propre famille
alors pour vous est ce que xavier dupont
de ligonnès est vivant ah oui je le
crois depuis le depuis le premier jour
pour vous y rendre et la borne basse
qu'il faut beaucoup de courage pour se
tuer il en faut plus pour suer que pour
donner la ville et la société tuez moi
ce qu'il ya je vois c'est qu'on l'aurait
retrouvée on aura retrouvé le corps non
pourquoi non non non non je pense pas
enfin je pense pas s'il avait pris un
cargo et que les pro élite de whisky des
médicaments et puis qui saute par-dessus
bref on leur tourne le nom mais c'est
aussi pour moi ce n'était pas dans ses
projets et puis quand vous
et tout le mode opératoire qui remonte
quand même un nom avant les crimes vous
comprenez que c'est un mec qui veut pas
mourir et un garçon qui va chercher son
fils deux jours après alors qu'il a tué
toute la famille qui va le chercher à la
gare en sachant qu'une heure après sera
mort c'est quelqu'un qui qui voit loin
pour vous aider ou alors il ya plusieurs
thèses une thèse assez assez forte sur
la thaïlande
parce qu'il n'ya pas d'extradition il ya
cette fameuse théorie ce dont je parle
c'est la théorie des trois frontières
c'est-à-dire que quand si vous vous
cachez dans l'ordre la thaïlande que
vous être près de l'avenue la hausse de
la birmanie du vietnam
vous pouvez ennuis franchir une
frontière si vous êtes repéré et qu'ils
avaient quand il était assez il savait
le commander à la problématique des des
fugitifs ont cavale
il ya aussi l'amérique du sud parce
qu'il parlait couramment espagnol et
puis qu il est brun aux yeux noirs il
peut passer
voilà inaperçue et il ya une dernière
thèse qui date d'il ya pas longtemps
qu'elle australie et c'est vrai que
l'australie en parlait beaucoup
enfin dans la dernière année de sa vie
même arthur ont parlé est-ce qu'il avait
déjà six enfants va déménager on va
s'installer en australie
c'est probable et l'australie moi
j'étais il ya un an c'est un pays si
vous la france elle est très très loin
donc du point de ligonnès et ça parle
sur d'accord mais le pays fait qu
attendu à la france donc on peut
vraiment sur ce cas chez bruno de
stabenrath l'ami impossible c est
je voulais dire c'est que dans le
bouquin et vous adresser à lui carrément
là vous dit carrément c'est toi qui
viendra à moi tu quand vous en aurez
marre de le rechercher si les niveaux
je sais quoi c'est ce qu'ils ont dit a
l'impression vous avez envie de lui dire
s'il y en a 1000 soit un homme assume
ses actes
c'est un homme a su taire si vous
regarder ce soir vous lui diriez quoi en
toi si on rentre en france il est passé
c'est pas si loin que ça piron toi quoi
si vous tes actes alors pas seuls
trouille
si parce que pour l'instant si vous
voulez sur la scène de crime ya pas d
adn n'ya pas d'empreintes digitales il
n'ya pas l'armé du crime maintenant xi
est d'un point de vue strictement
juridique si demain on l'arrête
c'est la justice de prouver sa
culpabilité ce qui n'est pas gagné
ouais moi ma seule trouille c'est que
mais je pense pas mais mason lockwood
c'est que devant les devant la justice
ils disent c'est pas moi qui ai tué ma
famille ça ce serait l'horreur facile à
effectuer il serait pas sauvés ont donc
laissé sa compagnie et qui devrait pas
dire tu peur c'est moi on va me tuer
d'un coup monté si la dea